good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the president of ukraine
vladimir zelensky addressed members of
congress today in a long and at times
moving speech
among other
things zielinski demanded the united
states shoot down russian aircraft over
his country the white house has not yet
agreed to do that but things do seem to
be moving very rapidly in that direction
not long after zolensky's address joe
biden announced the united states will
send a total of at least a billion
dollars of weapons to ukraine just this
week
members of congress in both parties then
emerge to say they don't think that's
enough watch
and the lethal drones we need more of
those in country as well
you know people talk about a no-fly zone
they can create their own if we give
them the military equipment and weapons
but there's a lot i think we can do
to help ukraine shoot down those russian
aircraft bring down those missiles a
package
that includes fighter jets and air
defense systems to the ukraine
immediately
so that we can have a ukrainian no-fly
zone what we need to do is make sure
that ukraine has the equipment it needs
in order to defend itself particularly
the skies
i think there's a bipartisan movement
right here provide them the migs
provide them the planes where they can
create a no-fly zone
so things are changing very fast for
weeks leaders in washington told us that
an american-backed no-fly zone in
ukraine would be unwise because it would
amount to an act of war against a
nuclear-armed russia as you can see
those views have evolved a lot
but in fairness congresswoman maria
salazar got there first salazar is a
longtime news anchor from miami who a
little over a year ago was elected to
congress as a republican she now sits on
the foreign affairs committee a week ago
a reporter from the gray zone asked
salazar what she thought of a no-fly
zone here's what she said
do you support a no-fly zone in ukraine
i've so i i support everything that has
to do with punishing vladimir putin and
helping the ukrainians wouldn't that
mean direct conventional warfare with
russia i don't know what it will mean
but you know freedom is not free so you
don't know what a no-fly zone will mean
if you have to shoot down russian planes
i mean of course
i don't know what it will mean but you
know freedom is not free now we made fun
of that answer last week when we first
showed you that clip but now what we
mocked is the consensus in washington we
don't know what's going to happen we've
got to do it immediately that's the
argument you're hearing
at this point no one wants to say it out
loud but it is true at this point a
shooting war with russia seems
inevitable how could war with russia not
be inevitable virtually everyone with
power is for it
we remain against it we think that
joining a war in eastern europe will
hurt this country though to be clear
when and if that war starts we will be
praying passionately for america's total
victory
unlike so many in the foreign policy
establishment we love this country above
all and we mean it hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else